No waiting room.
We're in.
Nah, this is the classic Scott.
Best call up ever.
30 minutes late minus one person.
Okay, you can't blame it on me.
I'm not the...
I showed up.
You are gonna have to call up.
Wait.
What?
Oh my god.
You told me not to care what the other time.
I didn't tell you shit.
I woke up.
That is fucked up.
Look, I woke up five minutes before our, no, 10 minutes
before our collab, but I showed up.
My only job was to show up.
I woke up half an hour before.
Half an hour.
That's so much better.
All right, well you diddo.
Diddo.
What's your excuse?
I like Uta.
You didn't even tell Uta the time of the collab.
I can't wait for Uta to wake up and just flame you.
I can't wait.
Uta waits all night for seven hours ago.
And I don't think she's gonna wake up soon.
Seven hours ago, that means she's gonna wake up in an hour.
Isn't it 530 in Japan?
What do you mean she's gonna wake up?
I don't know.
What do you mean?
It's 530 in Japan.
She's gonna wake up I messaged her one hour before our call
out, but she hasn't left behind me yet Yeah, one hour is
really a lot of time to like make sure you show up
Okay guys, okay before we say anything more how is our
volumes and everybody streams how how's the volume dick is
it okay i'm gonna put you guys up a little bit just in case
all right i'm gonna write oh i actually took a photo of my
oh my god i'm a mess i'm a mess
be sorry if it's not your fault you don't yeah why would you
be sorry if it's not your fault look look at me look at look
at me why do we have to look at you why do we have to look
at you look at me look at me i would be like who's not here
yet because ditto forgot to tell her the time
i'm sorry all right let's go make some money wait i'm not
ready yet i didn't even check if my volume's okay what we
just could you figure it out in midway well let's go what do
you mean okay ditto's a bit low okay let me i need to raise
up um ditto let me raise up ditto yes okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna I don't even know if my sound guy's alive too We how
do we point again?
How do we point?
How do we point I don't remember oh two I remember now here
two two two two all right whose fault is this that we're
late You have to apologize to utah.
Yeah, you have to apologize.
Actually, you're right.
You know what did us right?
It was right you gotta apologize You gotta apologize
wait we're waiting for crew what about
what about what about i'm going alone wait i don't know if
the volume's okay i don't know if the volume's okay it's
it's okay it's okay i think he's okay is it okay is it okay
is the volume okay guys is it okay now it's okay for me wait
what about me i'm talking about my stream You know, before
our stream started, wait, RPR, where did you go?
RPR, where did you go?
Wait for us, RPR.
Okay, before we started the stream chat, we were talking
about, you know, the whole it's RPR's fault and the lore
behind it.
It only had that whole thing started from one stream that
RPR wasn't even in.
It wasn't even in.
Yeah, that was almost two, two and a half years ago.
And you guys are still not letting it go bro.
I wasn't even part of the collab We never I've never said
anything after that stream and it's still going on It is
still going on.
I was literally sleeping
This the lore welcome to the lore are you going in?
Okay, let's go.
Whoa, I'm in.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff here.
Oh Oh yeah, there is.
I've been playing...
Okay, I've only played this game on launch.
So, like, I don't know any of the new stuff.
I've never seen any of the new stuff.
Guys, I forgot, guys.
Yeah, there's new stuff.
Oh, well, you've already played it recently, so you know
what the new things are.
I don't.
Oh, hey.
Yes, you do.
We're going to get hunted.
Wait, we're going to get hunted?
Why?
Oh, you took the battery.
Why did you take the battery?
Oh, shit.
shit i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving don't worry don't
worry leave leave the loot here i'll bring this over i'm
gonna bring it over i don't even know what the volume is
good guys is the volume good my sound guy's not here he's
sleeping one of my mods silent calcium i see you in my chat
wait where's the ladder how do we oh my god why is it so
bright why is it so is it really bright for you oh it's so
bright how where's the oh my god okay how do i get it over
here oh i got it oh my god it's so bright it's so bright
where's our ship where's our ship i don't know where it is
wait oh i see it
you know the accident is not your fault yeah it's rpr's
fault yeah yeah yeah rpr drove the truck Yeah, because I
need to hope that, okay, we are gonna do, we are gonna do
later company at 10 a.m.
And RPS said, no, I can't.
Yeah, yeah, you know what, we wanted to do the time that's
not 1 a.m.
PST.
Guys, RPR vetoed it.
The only one.
Uto, Ditto, and I, we were like, yeah, that's a good time.
Like, it would have been 5 p.m.
PST.
We're like, yeah, that's a good, right, right, Ditto?
We're like, yeah, that's a good time.
RPR was like no that's too too early that's too early that's
his fault yeah that's his fault so we have to reschedule it
yeah yeah yeah we had to reschedule it and now look what
happened Uto's not here wait we were we didn't know we were
you no no no I saw I saw something inside what what do you
mean there's alien what okay we go in together it can't
we'll go in Okay, okay, one, one, two, okay.
One, two, T.
Aren't you inside?
What are you doing?
I didn't trust you!
Because I know you were gonna...
You were gonna fuck with me!
Okay, okay, for real, for real.
Okay, okay, one, okay, ready?
One, two, three.
One, two, T.
Why did you do it?
Why are you inside?
Okay.
This one.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
One, two, three.
There's, okay.
I don't know.
Scott, Scott.
You're fine.
Fine, what happened?
Wait, what's going up?
Ah!
I see it.
Okay.
He's camping, he's camping the main door.
Why?
Why are you talking?
He said we have to make money.
Hello?
OPR?
Oh, it's this guy!
Isn't he's friendly?
That's a friendly guy.
Okay, I'm not scared anymore.
Did I?
I'm playing with...
I got you.
I'm helping.
Yeah, you bring that in.
We're helping.
We're so helpful.
Okay, we made a lot of money.
Yeah, we made a lot of money.
We made so much money.
Yeah.
Yippie.
You're so helpful.
We went to get the other one.
Alright, don't worry, Arvind.
I'll come in with you this time.
Yeah, I'm sure you are.
Arvind, don't worry.
No, I didn't.
We're going to head over with you.
Don't worry.
Wait, where are you?
Okay, wait for us.
Wait for us.
We'll wait for Ditto, and then we'll head there together.
I can't believe they're making Doki do all the work.
what do you mean what do you mean i carried the stuff is
that not enough the stuff that i took out from the dangerous
place not enough oh yeah yeah you could have done any of
that without ditto and i it's dumb and dumber behind me we
have g hundred yeah but he's greedy he likes money he's a
greedy i can't wait to sacrifice you guys for the See?
Look at it.
He doesn't care about the company.
He only cares about the money.
That's... Wait, RPR, where are you?
Oh, he's so fast.
He's so... Where is he?
RPR, what are you doing, RPR?
That's not scary.
That's RPR.
We know that's you.
We know that's you, RPR.
That's you.
That's not even a good impression.
That's not even good.
yeah we're not scared of you what are you doing because like
it's we're a company yeah yeah go make money then they will
make money with you it's dark it's time we have to go we
have to go back company together strong company together
strong What's going on?
What is that sound?
What is it?
It's us walking.
What are you talking about?
Wait, I hear something.
Yeah, I hear something.
Don't you hear it?
Oh, it's a dead end.
Yeah, I hear something.
I hear like a laughing, laughing sound.
What is that sound?
Why is it so dark?
Should I put my brightness up?
Why are you closing doors right here?
Yeah.
Why do you have to close the door?
not team thing we're a team yeah we're a team there's a jump
here yeah there's a jump what how what are you trying to do
huh what are you trying to do rpr huh he's gonna fall wait
he's gonna leave us we have to it's locked it's locked it's
locked what's that sound okay make the jump make the jump
Wait.
What rewarded.
What did she do?
What happened?
She fell out!
We have scared!
How do I make the jump?
How do I make the jump!
You can't jump!
How do I make the...
So go back a little bit, go back a little bit and jump from
the higher part.
Come on.
Ah!
Who do I make the jump?
Great!
Oh, I got it.
There's a Skinwalker with your voice!
Wait what?
There's a skidmocker with your voice.
There is.
I don't hear it.
I just heard it.
Oh, shit.
I don't like that.
That's not cool.
I like that.
I don't like that.
I just heard you twice.
It was really scary.
Oh, we're okay.
We're okay.
Oh, shit.
It's 9.51.
Wait, what time do we have to go?
Um, midnight, I think.
Okay.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
your time you know it's okay see look we survived i told you
company together strong i i heard you talking to me and then
i heard you in the distance talking and i was like wait was
i saying the same thing no a different thing oh that's
spooky that's for some laughing or some that was really
spooky that's freaky yeah we did it I didn't deserve it.
Yeah, no, that's your fault.
I can't believe that Ditto died.
How is that my fault?
She failed the jump.
That's so fucked up.
You let her... You didn't teach her!
She failed the jump!
You didn't teach her!
How do I teach him to jump?
You could have tried and jumped better.
She didn't ask!
That is not her fault.
Look at it.
Yeah, we failed the jump that you failed 15 times without
us.
Yeah, but I didn't die.
I helped you.
Yeah, so why did you help her?
Why did you help her?
She just jumped and died instantly.
There was no time for me to help her.
How much modulus?
What are you talking?
You you took the light off.
Yeah, look at that minus 20% minus 20% I took the lights off
Yeah, if you didn't change the lights everything would have
been fine off i'm landing the ship we're going i can't
handle this she died and you laughed she died and you
laughed to begin with i did laugh because it was funny
because she was saying oh and then she died all you heard
from dito was oh and then she died he's too without to say
anything oh my god someone my chat's right dito shouldn't
have had to ask You should have been a good person and
taught it.
Okay, okay, Doki.
But in my defense, Dito has been saying for the past, I
don't know how many days, that she's better than me at
lethal company.
So why do I need to teach someone that's better than me at
the game how to jump over a fence?
You know, you don't, you don't, you sort of write though,
Dito.
I know how to jump.
I know how to jump, but you took the life off and I couldn't
see anything.
So it's your fault.
Yeah, I can I couldn't see
Whoa, where do we wait?
Where do we go?
Oh, there's a key You can see now Yeah, see that we won't
die because we can see I have a key Oh, a key, I have a key
too Oh, why is it so dark?
Why is it small smoke?
Oh my god This is scary I'm scared Mission Okay, I got this
No No Look, don't
be Don't look, don't look Oh my god
It's me as, it's me as I what is that?
What is that?
No, no, no No, I said no, my god, this is why did I say
this?
Oh my god, he's, um, yeah, it's like an olive lip sign.
Oh, okay, okay.
If we stay here, if we stay here, he won't hurt us.
If we stay here.
Oh, wait, did you hear something?
Your voice.
There's other monitor too.
Oh, I don't hear my, no, I don't hear it.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're here together.
Okay.
It's okay.
I don't know how to fight with this one.
We have to go back.
Where is back?
I don't know where the back is.
Why?
Maybe this way.
I don't know where it is.
Are you sure?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
It's behind us!
Okay, okay, bye bye, bye, bye.
This is dead end!
I see it!
That end, okay, okay.
Ditto, where do we go?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ah!
I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
I believe me, what the fuck was that?
Oh my god, I'm going, I'm going, I'm leaving.
Where's the ship?
I don't know where the ship is.
Okay, we're gonna, we're okay, we're alive.
Where's the ship?
I don't know where it is.
This shit went from zero to 100 so fast.
Look, it's survival of the fittest.
I have loot.
Where's the ship?
I'm so confused.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I found it.
yes i found it this is important we need we need we need
loot okay look we need the loot because because ditto keeps
dying so we need the money hey is what happened to ditto is
ditto dead i was gonna help her because there was a thing on
her head yeah but then bracken came and i was like yeah
we're good is she dead yeah she She's dead.
I mean, why did you let her die again?
She's bad.
What do you want from me?
Whoa!
We're leaving.
That's fucked up.
She's not bad.
You're just a bad teacher.
I was not even teaching her anything.
How is it my fault?
She's better than me, apparently.
Yeah.
I don't she's supposed to be teaching me she's better than
me I don't know this is the second time that you this is the
second time you did it teacher okay oh my god oh my god dude
you killed me yeah you killed me how did I kill you I can't
believe you I was gonna help I was gonna help you.
I was gonna help you get the thing off your head by fucking
through the door, but then Bracken showed up.
And then that was it, that was it.
I can't believe it.
Can't believe you would do that to her.
You were supposed to be our supervisor.
You're like our supervisor.
You're not supervising good enough.
You should see the DMs between me and her.
She says she's better than me.
Is that true?
She's a part-timer.
title your title's leader that means you're better you said
you're better than me so you should you should show me where
to go she's a part timer you're so you're better than
You're just better than me text by my way.
So you're not better than me.
Ditto.
Are you better than RPR Ditto?
Are you better?
Yeah, I'm better than RPR.
Okay, then go in first.
I follow RPR.
Wait, but if you're better, then you should be the leader.
No, no, no.
You should be the leader, Ditto.
You're better.
I know my place.
I'm bad.
She's so dead.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, where do we go, Jito?
Come here, come here.
Where?
Go first.
Where is here?
Uh, side, side, side.
Okay.
All right, we're behind you.
We're following you.
Oh my god.
There's a turret!
You just gotta just walk next to a turret!
Yeah, but we're okay.
It's not...
It's not working.
There you are!
It's a turret!
Wait, what?
Wait, let's do it!
Where is the turret?
No!
That doesn't!
That'll be bad.
The next to it is that blue!
Wait, no, we should run past it!
You can do it!
See?
Look, you did it, RPR!
What is this?
The back rooms?
What is this shit?
See?
I'm better than you.
She wasn't scared.
You almost died three times, Ditto.
It's okay.
I don't know.
She seems to... She didn't die, though.
She's standing next to the turret and she's like, what?
That's true.
Wait, that's true though.
Oh, I'm scared.
It's so dark, yeah.
It's so dark.
Wait, I thought dinner was like...
What is that?
I've never seen that before.
Look, look, look, look, look, look.
What is that?
Don't look away, you fucking Look, look!
Okay!
If you look away, pause.
It's like the annual.
So if I do this?
No!
Help me!
I got a flashlight.
What is that?
No!
Keep looking!
Go!
Now it's over!
Wait!
It's over!
Wait, she fell off the path, didn't she?
Oh my god, I just feel so creepy I didn't realize I didn't
realize that's a hole I didn't even realize that's a hole I
was just scared I was so scared I was so scared I just so
scared Oh no He's so sad Okay Wait can you open the door can
it open doors door oh is he dead yeah can he open doors wait
wait wait wait i hear i hear your voice too but you hear my
voice i don't i don't hear any of the skin walkers i'm so
dead i did i install it wrong oh okay he's dead in oh he's
dead and he's so fucked
Wait, oh, he's right there.
Wait, he can open doors.
It can open doors.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Oh, what if it was so funny if there was a monster behind
him?
That would be so funny.
Oh, what the heck?
He can open the door too.
What?
Escape.
Oh.
I need the fucking side door, chat.
Wait, we can't...
He can't die, though, because we have so much loot.
If he dies, we lose everything.
OPR, if he dies, we lose everything.
What's the sound?
Is this dead?
No?
No, no.
He's trying to find a side door.
His thing is not following me without making any audio.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I saw it!
I saw it!
I saw what?
I saw that!
I saw it!
No, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, I don't think he
saw it.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, she went, she went the other side.
Oh, I'm just gonna fuck out of me, bitch.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
Oh my god, he didn't see it.
I saw it.
How am I gonna get out?
Oh, that's so scary.
Oh my god.
That's so scary.
Oh, that's so scary.
It's so dead.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ, I was almost dead.
Jesus.
Oh my god I'm dead I'm dead I think it's a What is he doing?
Oh my god Oh my god what the fuck Oh my god I'm actually
dead like it's over Oh Oh my god What is he gonna do What is
he gonna do
What the fuck is that?
Is it over?
I think so.
I don't think he's gonna live.
What if I...
There's no way.
Fuck it.
There was no way out there.
I live!
I don't like this guy.
I have no weapon.
Bro!
I don't like this guy.
Oh, P.I.
The coin head is fine, but the big fucker with the wide
shoulders came, man.
Oh, P.O.
How could you do this?
Why didn't you tell me there was a hole there?
How did you guys?
I jumped into the hole.
Yeah..
We lost everything.
Yeah, we lost everything.
We jumped into the hole and it's some platforms.
I didn't know how I thought there was the same platform.
You didn't tell me.
I didn't tell you.
You didn't tell me, you're the leader.
Oh, your toilet.
We're so dead.
There's no way it's zero days.
We don't have anything.
Oh.
What's wrong?
How is anyone?
We all died.
There's no reason.
We have no money.
The company can't kill us if we kill ourselves first.
our life was in our own hands oh we had like 400 yeah yeah
you guys definitely have 400 you guys are great oh now we're
good i can't believe we're getting a game over already i
thought i was playing with pros what happened oh i'm just
doing my part i was playing with pro players
Guys, I was the baby.
You know what?
You know, if Udo was here, this wouldn't have happened.
It would be good.
If Udo was here, she would have helped carry us.
She's she's Bob Heyer.
She's very good at this game.
Yeah, yeah, she would be a team player.
So really, it's Dito's fault we're losing because she didn't
tell Uto the time.
Yeah, honestly, I agree.
Because I know it's not my fault.
I showed up.
I was a guest.
I did my part.
That was my only job.
Put it on my schedule.
Put it on my schedule and then show up.
That was my only job.
I didn't look at the hazard level and now it's foggy.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
I can't see.
So many ads.
What is Tyler Wong doing?
I can't see.
I'm here.
Alright, let's walk in here.
Oh my gosh, where is the door?
Oh, there's the door.
Okay.
Okay, other one.
Where did he go?
There's a turret.
That's the only way we'd go, though.
No, we'll go in here.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh, there's a mine.
What's that?
Oh, is that a key?
Yeah.
Well, I heard another mine.
Oh, there's another mine.
Where is it?
Do we have a house?
I hear it.
Don't you hear the...
up yeah but i don't see it wait i hear my voice oh so yeah
woman's gonna go in okay i heard my own voice somewhere yeah
but you were talking yeah i don't know that was a skin
walker or like or like somebody's mic i did i mean i didn't
hear the skin walker but oh maybe it's the echo okay wait
isn't this the bracken room wait there's a key you need to
take it yeah this is the back room like easter egg I guess
okay what's that okay there is a tattered metal sheet I'll
take that wait where is that it's like stuck yeah how do I
grab it I took it I took it oh okay Geek is jumping time.
I made it.
Okay.
There's two engines here, but I'm a fool.
I can do this.
Wait.
I can do it.
Can you carry this key?
Yeah, I can carry it.
Okay, there's two engines here, and those are expensive.
Uh-huh.
What do we do?
We have to find the side door.
We can't jump backwards.
Wait, why can't we jump backwards?
Why?
Why can't?
Because we're carrying an engine.
Oh Wait, why did you jump forward?
I mean we could jump backwards.
Wait, why can't I see shit?
Yeah, why can't why is this?
Oh, the exit is here.
The exit is here.
Wait, where?
Right here below.
Oh, I can't see Jack's shit.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll bring it up.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm doing my part.
I'm doing my part.
Me too.
Yeah.
Look at us, go.
We're still helpful.
I don't know.
I can't see.
Where are you?
Oh, left side, left side.
Okay, left side?
Okay.
Yeah.
I can't jump.
I can't.
My hands are so full.
Wait.
Where are you, Ditto?
I can't see.
I need, I'm alive.
Under you, under you.
You're under?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to follow you.
You're like my dog.
dog why not you know like blind people with dog what the
heck what does this mean man what is monkey boy oh no is it
it's a bird wait what the fuck is that oh okay that's just
the bird okay thank god okay i was gonna say how that was an
enemy yeah it's my friend wait did i put it in okay why is
this true so fox because like rpr didn't check the the land
and it's Ah!
What was that?
What's that?
You bitch!
You fucking bitch!
You fucking let me in!
You fucking!
Let me in!
Oh, fuck.
We're leaving, right?
Get us in!
Then I said, I swear to God, I will yell and then I swear to
God, I swear to God, a dog's gonna come over.
And then there will be no power and it'll be your fault.
A dog's gonna come over and I hope the fucking ship dies.
Yes, yes, yes.
Open the door.
Oh, we're in.
Yay!
That was a nice one.
It was a homemade flashbang and I wanted to try employee.
That's you.
You got the laziest employee Most paranoid.
Yeah, brought everything out.
Yeah.
Oh, not according to the company.
You're the laziest Yeah, because you guys stole my loot We
got the loot together Not We were there with you when we got
the loot stop slacking off I brought us the most I bring us
the most money every time that's not true because the last
game we didn't make any money we didn't make any money last
game but I had the most money on my dead body yeah but you
were dead that doesn't count you know what we don't need you
Tiddo and I can can do it without you right Tiddo Alright,
yeah, okay, we'll go.
You're going first.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why me first?
Okay, because like we're a team.
We, okay, okay.
Listen to me.
We're gonna- Why me?
Why me?
Why was it me?
I'm so fucked up!
I don't fucking want it to be now!
What the fuck?
Is dead or dead?
Is she dead?
I feel like she's dead.
Did she not?
Did she not make it in?
Oh, fuck.
It's the back room.
I'm not gonna check because of what it'd be.
Oh my god, there's nothing here.
Where's...
She's dead.
Oh my god, she's actually dead.
Where's the ship?
I don't remember where the ship is.
Okay, I need to take her back to the ship.
I don't know where it is.
I can't believe she's dead.
Wait, you didn't even leave the ship?
That's so fucked up!
You didn't even leave the ship!
That's Sam!
What have you been doing?
Did you bring any loot?
Where you don't need me.
I brought the loot.
And there's no loot in your hands, but you don't need me,
right?
I brought her.
Yeah, Spito's dead body.
That's not loot.
Well, it's fine.
You guys don't need me, but she died within three seconds of
being without me.
And you're throwing back.
She died!
She rolled!
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
She caused her own death.
That was not...
She tried to pick up the fucking- I'm going in!
I'm 1HB!
Would it be fucked up if I start this shit while-
Would it be fucked up if I start this shit while he's up
there?
Look, I- I did my job!
Has been cast.
Okay, I didn't do that, though.
Okay, that's not my fault.
RPR!
RPR, the boat has been casted!
It's okay.
That's not my fault.
Ditto was the one that voted.
I'm not leaving the ship now that I know.
Okay, the moment...
Okay, guys.
The moment...
Wait, I didn't know if he's gonna come back!
I need to see if he comes back!
If he comes, and the moment I see his shadow, like a shadow
of him or hear his voice, I'll make sure the ship flies away
so he can see the ship flying away before he can get on.
Wait, check the monitor.
That's me.
No, he's still alive, see?
Oh, I could leave while he's still out there.
Oh my god, look at him.
Look, there he is.
Whose body is that?
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, man, what happened?
Why did you just leave me behind, you dumbass?
I didn't do anything!
I was bringing loot back!
I'm too useless, fucking dumbass!
I didn't do anything!
She voted!
What did you do that, dumbass?
I didn't know!
You die?
You waste our money!
And then you fuck us!
I didn't know!
I was just on the ship!
I didn't do anything!
I didn't know!
What is that command?
Don't click that shit.
It makes the ship leave.
Oh, it's I- okay, okay, okay.
Okay, you're right to the side.
Not only did she die, she costed us some money, And then she
took the ship away.
So I died too.
I was just chilling in the ship.
I don't know what was going on.
Why were you hiding the ship?
Because I was 1 HP.
Because Zeno fucking set up the whiteness.
I was 1 HP.
Let's do it.
We can do this together.
We don't need our PR.
We go this way.
Okay.
Yeah, we're gonna do it.
We go this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're a team.
Let's go.
We don't need our PR.
Oh, that's okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Our PR.
We swap.
We're swapping.
Our PR.
We swap.
You go the other way.
There's a turret.
You're better at that What's that sound Do you hear that Oh,
he took the battery Why did you take the battery Oh my god
You're showing it again Why did you take the battery We
can't see Yeah Yeah, how are you gonna split up I'm like
Don't worry We'll bring this back We'll bring this back
Right there We're gonna do our job Okay, I will bring it
back Yeah, yeah, don't jump Don't jump Don't jump If we
jump, this thing breaks down.
Oh, I see.
Alright, nice.
Okay, where's...
Oh, there's the ship.
Wait, where's the ship?
Do you remember where the ship is?
If one of one?
Here, here, here, here.
Okay, I'm going to follow you.
I'm going to follow you.
I don't remember.
You can click light.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see it now.
Look at us, yo.
We're such good.
We're such good workers.
See?
We got loot.
Yeah.
We got loot for the company.
Yeah, we're making money.
All right.
Okay, I went the wrong way.
I went the wrong.
It's this way.
Nice.
Look at us.
Money.
We're team players.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't need him.
Where's the main entrance?
I have no idea.
Wait, where's the...
Where is there?
Maybe just...
Here, here, there, over there.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can go down.
Let's do the side entrance because he's at main entrance.
We'll do the side entrance.
I see.
I'll do the side entrance here.
Okay.
We can do this.
I believe in us.
We don't need our PR.
Okay.
You don't need him.
Yeah, yeah, we're better than him or two of us two is big
better than one Yeah, yeah, see what we have a sign Yeah,
already Oh, we have two weapons.
Look at that.
Okay, okay.
We should kill.
We should kill our PR with this Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
before before we we take off the ship.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, let's go to
main entrance We go to the main entrance and we wait for
him.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, we wait for him.
Can we go on top?
Yeah, we go, he's here.
He's here.
This way.
We go up to the main entrance and we wait for him.
And then we steal his loot after.
That's nice.
Yeah, he won't know.
He won't know.
He'll...
Look
at all this loot!
Okay, okay, we will stand.
You stand on the other side and then I'll stand.
Nice.
Nice plan.
This is such a good plan.
So good.
Yes.
We can just wait here.
We can't wait here.
We're camping like you Yeah, yeah, yeah We're gonna wait for
him And then when he comes out, we'll be like Yeah, prior
flying Yeah, yeah Yeah, we're gonna steal his money We're
gonna steal He won't be ready for him then I think he will
get back in maybe One hour, one or two hours Yeah, yeah,
yeah, he has to He's gonna, he has to Because he has so much
loot on him we can we won't be able to do this we'll be fine
okay what what if he he's dead what if he's dead if he's
dead he would start the ship he would start the ship if he's
dead yeah yeah yeah there's no way you would start the ship
he would be like look at these dumbasses and then he's gonna
start the ship like yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't i think he's
still alive He has to be still alive.
There's no way.
He's going to come through this entrance here.
We wouldn't hear him.
If we went through the side entrance, we would hear him on
the side.
Okay.
Yeah, don't worry.
We're ready.
We're ready for him.
He was cocky for too long.
We were tired of his leaders.
ship he's a bad leader right dido yes he's a bad leader so
we have to get rid of him oh my if uto was here if oh wait
he's what he's doing he died he didn't hear that right did
he Do you think he heard that?
Do you think he heard that?
No, right?
He didn't hear all of that, right, guys?
He didn't.
No, right, guys?
He didn't hear that.
It's okay.
We're coming back to the ship.
Wait, where did Ditto go?
Wait, where did the Where the fuck did Ditto go?
Ditto, where are you?
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here!
I can't align.
Oh yeah, here, no, we were fine.
Look at that, we lived!
We lived!
Wait, what the fuck was that?
What?
Ditto?
What is that?
What's that sound?
Wait, wait, wait.
I hear something.
What's that sound?
I'm gonna start shooting.
Oh, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Oh my god.
Look,
we live.
We have loot and we lived.
The most laziest employee.
Wow.
So lazy.
The most laziest employee.
I know.
He's so lazy.
What happened?
Why were you so lazy?
What you did?
RPR?
Why don't you talk to us?
RPR, why won't you talk to us?
Are you muted?
RPR?
RPR, you don't talk to us.
I'm gonna throw our loot off the ship.
I'm crazy enough to do you don't believe me I'm gonna
fucking throw this side off I'm gonna throw I'm gonna throw
this off the off the clip right now
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw this off if you don't talk to us
I fear why don't you talk to us Don't do this.
Don't do this, RPR.
Wait, don't talk to us.
Talk to us.
I'm here.
Don't understand.
Oh!
I'm flying!
Don't see, I'm flying!
I'm
good.
Test net, I think.
Goodbye.
What?
What the fuck?
Bye.
We made money.
We got money.
Wait, oh wait.
Guys, I don't think we made the money, guys.
Yay, we reached the quota.
I just want you to do it.
know, Doki, that when you least expected, in the darkness of
the caves, I'm coming for you.
Why me?
What did I do?
How did I kill you?
I'm coming for you.
We didn't even kill you.
We were like alive.
When you least expected, in the deepest, darkest parts of
the dungeons, I'm coming for you.
What did we do?
We were like waiting for you.
Waiting for me to kill me as I'm carrying 300 Plus crap on
me.
Yeah You think I didn't see that?
You think I didn't see all of that?
And then you leave us.
You leave me and Vito with all the loot outside the ship.
So we just lost 500.
But we made a hunt.
We made the quota.
Go back to part of you.
I'll play alone.
Oh my god, he's angry.
Why is he so angry?
What do we do?
What is wrong with him?
Why is he so angry?
If Uto was here, if Uto was here, he was talking.
No, no.
But we didn't even do anything.
It was just talking.
Ew.
Yeah.
We're just talking.
We're just having a conversation.
We haven't done anything.
Yeah, we can't talk now.
I mean, entrance.
Yeah, what's wrong?
We can't even talk now?
It's a brain.
What do we get there?
Oh, we have to jump.
You first.
Okay.
I believe in you.
Yes.
Whoa.
Okay, my turn.
Woo.
We did it.
Okay.
There's a door over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not a main entrance.
Let's go.
We don't need him.
Oh, wait, wait.
There's a loot.
I got loot.
Okay, I already got loot.
I already got loot!
Okay, nice.
What is this?
What is that?
Oh, it's a switch.
I don't like that.
What did you do?
I don't know.
I don't like that.
What did you do?
Okay, the light is on.
Oh, okay, I turned everything on.
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait, what's that sound?
Are you cursed?
Wait, he's cursed!
That's a cursed item!
Okay, he's gonna kill us, he's gonna kill us.
I think he's gonna try to kill us!
That's a cursed item!
What was that item?
So like when you hold on to it, a ghost monster is gonna
chase you.
Ah Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that cursed?
Is that maybe?
Oh, it's just a toy.
Oh, no never mind.
I lied.
It's just a toy.
But here, this item.
Oh, look, we found this.
This.
Yeah.
Nice.
Go back.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go back where we came from.
Because like, RPG is going to do the main room, right?
right yes so we could do this so we can do like the the side
room we haven't gone this way yet is this the back room oh
never mind oh that's just the back room okay yeah there's
nothing there we could go we go left we go here oh there's
nothing this is so small but he was here so we could go this
way okay because he was on the other side dog i know so dog
oh it's turret turret turret okay we know this way there's
that turret here too there's like oh there he is hey rpr hey
rpr hey you ran away he's not talking why are you not
talking yeah why are you don't talk to us why don't you
don't talk to us yeah we're good people I don't understand.
We've been so nice to him.
I think he was here.
He went all the way here because all the doors are open.
Okay.
I don't know where we're going now.
Wait, there's a...
Yippee!
Oh, hey, look at all this loot!
Wait, why does he hate us?
Oh, he hates me!
What did he do?
I'm still in the loot!
I stole him!
He's angry!
Okay, okay.
Okay, live, live, live, live, live, live!
Okay, I'm 1 HP, I'm 1 HP.
Okay, okay.
I'm glad you're alive.
I'm alive.
But where do we go?
I don't know where to go.
Oh, um...
I'm gonna follow you.
Maybe, maybe this way?
Oh no.
Wait, wait.
I'm lost.
I'm already lost.
Maybe this way.
To the ship.
I can't believe it.
I stole his stuff.
To go to the ship.
Where's Apio?
Is he dead?
No, I think he's alive.
He was dead?
He would start the ship.
Shh.
I can't I can't you rise to skinwalker oh my god we did it
yay I realized the laziest again you literally got me killed
how do we what do we do what you made the little dumbass mad
which dumbass which was the guy that want to loot yeah but
like why did he chase just give him a piece of loot because
you guys brought him to me
it's unbelievable i believe in karma karma's coming for you
did you get killed by the bug yeah he got look at her you
got killed by a bug look at it you guys can't believe it you
got killed by a party car is coming Karma is coming.
I didn't die.
What do you mean?
He got killed by a bug.
Look at it.
That's our fault, right?
Ditto, what do we do?
I feel like he's getting karma.
Not us.
We've been good.
I only died one time.
He's trying to...
He's gonna revenge us.
Yeah, no.
If he revenge us, he loses everything.
Whoa, Banto.
Wait, I got something.
Oh, you got something?
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, we're already doing our job.
Karma doesn't exist for us because we're good people, right?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, we're good.
Yeah, there's nothing in here.
Oh, I...
I think someone has nothing in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's not...
He's too dark.
There's nothing in here, too.
I think we have to go to this side.
It's staying in.
Yeah, it's all dead end.
All dead end.
Hello?
Wait, dead end's here.
So we have to go out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, there's something here.
I have a cabin.
Oh, nice!
It's moving.
Look at us.
We're so efficient.
We're so good at this.
Wait, it's all dead end Dead end?
Wait, I should go here.
Is it a dead end?
Yeah, that's dead end.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
This is all dead end.
Oh, I guess we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, we just bring this back.
Yay!
RPR has been the laziest employee.
yeah yeah we're doing our job he can make any profit i know
he's not gonna make any money for the company oh he got the
battery okay he took the battery again but wouldn't be funny
we just start the ship i think i think i think he's gonna
quit um okay but like if you do it if you do it
You should have bought that?
Yeah, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
He told that, he told, yeah.
No, no, no!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think if you do it, he won't be bad.
Okay.
Okay, we have, we have one quarter.
So, this time it's my turn.
You guys are insane in the fucking head.
I didn't do it.
It was Ditto.
I wasn't even the one that did it.
No.
Let's go.
Let's go here.
I can't believe he was the racist employee again though.
Are we gonna make quota?
Are we gonna make...
No, no, no, we have.
Should we go get the loot?
We will, yeah.
Our last time.
Yeah, we got this.
We can do this.
Yeah, we can do it.
Go.
fucking make money we are making money look at all the stuff
we brought in do you have one i think it's because we keep
splitting up if we hello go make money go make money i'm
done i'll make no money no we made money no go make money go
make money wait why did you take us to the hardest world why
did you take us I'm done making money.
I made enough money.
You guys can make money.
This is so hard for me to be with us.
It's the last day if you guys don't make money, you will
lose.
So go make money because I'm not doing anything.
Come with us.
It's the hard world.
No, I'm good.
We need help.
I'm going to watch you guys through the cameras here.
No, we don't have a walkie talkie.
Here, I'll buy you walkie talkies.
But that's a waste of our money.
We're going to waste money.
Here, go pick up walkie talkies, guys.
I'm sure you better.
I'm on a strike.
I don't care.
Are you mad at us?
What do we do our fear?
Let's mediate.
Go make money or we die.
But where's the walkie-talkie?
I don't mind dying.
I don't mind dying because I already been killed multiple
times.
What is... I have, I have no puppy.
Wait, where's the walkie-talkie?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, yeah, remember this way.
But you need the walkie-talkie too, RPR.
shit
They're so fucking dead
Where's the edge
Ah!
Dara, Dara, I'm here.
Dara, it's gonna make money.
Right here.
It's gonna make money.
Dara, do you think you...
He's mad at us, do you think he's so mad at us?
Yeah, he's so mad at us.
But what did we do?
Why did we do so?
We need like 50, we need like 50.
Yeah, yeah, why don't we just go, let's go to side entrance,
side entrance.
This one, this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know what we did.
We were good employees.
What is supposed to eclipse?
Is this high?
Yeah, this is high.
How high?
What's that?
There's a face hugger.
What is this...
Oh, it's a bag!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He, like, grabs your face.
Okay, okay.
Oh, is this 50?
Uh, check.
Let me shake.
Scan, scan.
Oh, we need one more.
We need one more item.
We need one more.
Oh, I found the main entrance.
Okay, okay, okay, I found one more.
Oh, okay, okay, we made it, we made it!
Dido?
Oh, I think she's dead.
I think she's dead.
I don't know how to get home.
No.
This way, this way.
Okay.
This way.
I'm not dead.
We got money.
Wait, Ditto crashed.
Wait, the game crashed.
The game...
He crashed the game!
Whoa!
The game crashed?
Oh my god, bro.
I was lagging so high
Like running in this in the stall standing still we did it
our VR we did it All you got was two pieces of loot.
You proud of your tools for that?
You're proud of two.
Yeah, we made quota.
Do I need to remind you that you murdered me?
You murdered me multiple times while I was carrying hundreds
of thousands of scrap.
Okay, you dying is not murder.
We were...
Are you leaving me on the planet?
It's not murder.
We didn't do anything.
You leaving me?
Let me put this into perspective.
Let me put this into perspective, okay?
You guys left me on the planet three times already while I
was carrying loot.
And then one time I go inside and you guys actually find
loot which are top signs, I accidentally died with four
pieces of loot, a lot of money on me, and I spectate you
guys, learning to kill me as I walked through the door,
carrying the loot to save you guys from the fucking company!
It was just talk, we didn't do it!
Yeah, we didn't do it!
Yeah, we didn't do it, we were just talking!
We were just talking!
Do you think that we are gonna do that to you?
Yeah, we were just talking.
There's no way we're gonna do that to you.
Yeah, it was just a fantasy.
It was like a fantasy.
Yeah.
There's no way we can do that.
Yeah, why would we do that to you?
You had so much money.
Yeah.
We need 70 more.
I got a key.
No, don't don't sell keys.
Don't sell keys.
Why not?
But we need more money We have enough money.
Oh, okay Like we did it.
It's over we lost wait what I thought you said we had you're
carrying you're carrying Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, see I'm gonna sell everything 14.
I sell the key.
I'm gonna sell everything Is that 40?
That's ten dollars.
Here's the key.
24 we're lost no no i have a key no no no that key is three
that we have a key we did it we're gonna use the corner yeah
wait there's coffee mug okay coffee mug coffee mug yeah yeah
yeah see i told you the key works yeah we did it we did it
you're lucky we did it i found the coffee mug
Nice nice.
Yeah.
I'm selling it.
Oh, I saved the day.
Scammy.
Yippee.
Okay, shut the fuck up.
Okay.
It would have literally up 3,000 scrap right now if you guys
didn't kill me.
Look, you didn't do anything.
You killed yourself.
Yeah.
You're crazy.
You guys are literally plotting against us.
No, no, no.
You know, if Uto was here, if Uto was here, you wouldn't be
yelling at us like this.
Yes, I would!
We're on the same fucking team!
Yeah, so why are you so mean to us?
Are you crazy in the head?
Like, hello?
here in the past hour with me?
I'm playing solo!
We got the coffee mug!
Right, Ditto?
Yeah!
We got the coffee mug that got us a quota.
Make money.
More money, less talking.
We need walkie-talkies.
Let's get walkie-talkie.
I'm gonna buy stuff.
Make money.
buy stuff i'm gonna buy stuff help store money well i'm
gonna buy something that won't be a waste of money all right
oh my god gonna buy i'm gonna buy this walkie talkie i did
it i bought something nice don't worry i bought something
useful let's wait for the okay let's wait for the package he
he go by himself he go on again don't worry don't worry I
have if he die he's gonna blame yeah he's gonna believe us
if he dies but it's not our fault yeah we're shopping look
look what I got what is this how much How much?
It was like, it's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, don't, don't
worry.
Look.
I think it's gonna, um, no, no, this is a good purchase.
But look, it's a good purchase.
It's like motivation losing.
Look.
Nice one, nice one, nice one.
It's good money.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
buy something else let's see store we can buy okay let's buy
walkie-talkie we'll buy two okay okay walkie oh my god let's
get a table wait we can buy a toilet by what toilet go look
look look look toilet yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i have never
seen toilet yeah yeah we have to use this bathroom place
look at that toilet it's needed nice nice oh my god okay
okay shoot we don't tell him wait wait is it inside oh my
god look at the toilet it's here Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's why I walkie-talkie.
Okay, I'll follow you.
I'll follow you walkie-talkie for real.
Okay.
Let's get out.
Wait, we can move it.
Let's move this.
Okay, wait.
Can we move it?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm not even flying.
Let's get the walkie-talkie.
Alright.
Okay.
I will walkie-talkie.
Let's go.
How do I use this?
Okay.
Hello?
I got it.
Okay.
Yeah, I can hear you.
Hello.
Okay, I can hear you too.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Look.
Where's the entrance?
And the...
Maybe go straight?
Okay, I'll follow you.
Here, here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
See, we're being so...
Careful!
Oh yeah, it's a fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's... You can die from that.
Yeah, I have every... I have every die from this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is expensive walkie-talkie.
How much?
It was like... It was like $20.
Where's the entrance?
Oh, there, there, there, there, there!
I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it.
Okay, let's go.
We have walkie-talkies now.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff!
There's...
There's a lot of stuff!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello, do you hear me?
Okay, okay.
We're taking back.
We're taking back?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're taking back.
Okay, okay, look at us.
Okay.
With this, we can make a lot of money.
Yeah, we can, we did it.
We're doing our part.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go.
We're so helpful.
We're making money.
Ah!
Okay, I'm 1 HP.
I'm 1 HP.
Oh, me too.
Me too.
Okay, we shouldn't, we shouldn't...
We can come from this.
This way, this way.
I don't think we should go inside.
We're 1 HP.
We did our part.
Wait I have to wait for this.
Alright.
Wait, where's the ship?
Do you know where the ship is?
I never know where the ship is.
Maybe on our left side?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Yeah, I scanned it.
Which one?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's this way.
I think?
Okay, no, I don't.
I don't see it.
I'm lost.
Oh.
Where is this?
No, I didn't lie.
I'm just stupid.
Where's the shame?
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
You're just stupid!
No!
You can be stupid.
Only up here, stupid is enough, okay?
Okay, maybe...
You can be more stupid.
We can all be...
Okay, I'm stupid, but not that stupid.
Okay.
Only up here is enough.
Yay!
We made money!
Wait, where's our boom box?
Wait, where did our music box go?
Oh, I have it!
Wait!
Okay, okay.
Is up here dead?
Is he?
Oh, no!
He's dead!
Wait, is he dead?
See?
No, maybe he's hiding.
Is he hiding?
I think he's dead?
No, no, he has to be hiding.
He doesn't move.
Wait, how do I...
Where's my walkie-talkie?
Did I drop it?
Okay, I'm gonna go back again.
Where's my walkie-talkie, though?
Oh, we should go move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just drop down, maybe.
Oh, maybe we should all go back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should go back and get the loot.
Oh, my.
Oh, where's my walkie-talkie?
This way, this way.
I think I dropped it when I fell.
Okay.
I think it's...
Is it this way?
You call it?
I don't know how to get back.
I don't know.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I follow you.
I'm already lost.
This way?
I think, I think you drop it at the main entrance.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, I think so.
When I was picking stuff up.
Don't worry.
I have music.
Okay, we have...
Oh.
Oh my gosh, I hear... I hear... I hear the key's voice.
I hear your voice!
What is that?
There's things behind us.
There's my walkie-talkie!
She's walkie-talkie!
Why is she talking to you?
Grab it, grab it, grab it.
I got this.
Okay, okay.
Go back, go back.
Wait, it's dark now so there's a lot of monsters outside.
Yeah, don't worry.
I have this.
I don't know where to go.
Maybe this way.
Okay.
Oh, this...
That's me, that's me.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Oh
Karma has come out and bit you in the ass once again I
made so much money that run and you guys are fucking around
with walkie-talkies and that's why we I lose I made like
over 400 in that run die to a break and just to watch you
guys fuck with a toilet and fuck fuck this toilet what
happened to
Do we get our money back?
Do we get our toilet money back?
Oh my god, no!
You guys don't get to have fun until we make money in this
fucking house!
But we did make money!
We made zero, you all died!
We were!
Our toilet!
I was on toilet!
We worked so hard!
Did he delete it?
No, it's in storage.
It's in the storage.
I bought his walkie-talkies.
I bought him his walkie-talkies so we can use it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we can.
Yeah, I couldn't buy us a boombox.
We were broke.
We didn't have enough money.
It's in his storage.
He kept it.
Oh, our walkie-talkie.
Nice, nice.
Oh, here.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yay.
Where's the other one?
Oh, there it is.
Yay!
It's here.
Let's do it.
Let's go.
Let's make money.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have walkie-talkies.
Don't make money.
We're gonna make some money.
Yay.
How do we get up?
We have to go another way.
Why does he always split up with us?
Why doesn't he want to work with us?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here.
Don't understand.
We're like a team, right?
Yeah, well, he always go alone.
Yeah, yeah, why does he always go alone?
If he stops going alone, then we wouldn't die.
Yeah, there's no point to play with cheap people if he wants
to go.
Yeah, yeah, if he's in a solo, no wonder he keeps dying.
if he had us with him he wouldn't be dying we're trying to
be a team player let's find him let's try to find him RPR
RPR what's that what is that what happens it's a slum does
it kill you yeah walk into it yeah walk into it let's see
what happens no I think it kills you right it's gonna kill
us no it's okay we something is gonna kill you anyway no we
have to work together make a knife where we are we have to
work together as a team
we can work together we had i'm gonna die i think he's gonna
die isn't he
where did he go oh he's over there Oh, go get the loot while
I'm dealing But we want to work with you I can't move
There's a slime in front of me Go get the loot Okay, we'll
get the loot Okay, okay I got loot I got loot, I got loot,
look See, I got loot Yeah, bring it out the door
I did it Okay, I'll go this side Okay Oh, yeah, I'm going
There is a bug What do I do He
said, he said, he said, oh my god, he said I'm sorry, I'm
sorry He said, he said, I took I didn't do anything!
I took this stuff!
He's dead!
We go!
Let's go!
Let's go, baby!
What did we go?
What was this monster?
Oh, I don't know!
I don't know how do we get home.
How do we get home?
He's dead again!
Why is our ship?
I don't know, I don't know where this ship is.
I know I always relied on you.
What happened, what happened inside?
I don't know, I don't know, he just, there was just so many
things happening, I don't know what happened.
I just saw him flying.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, it's okay, I, I took his load.
Oh my God.
Wait, where's home?
Where's home?
Oh, here, here.
I can't remember this way.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know what happened.
There were so many monsters.
And then he died.
Well, he died.
He did it again.
I don't know.
I don't know how he died this time.
oh there he is he died every time i know he's the laziest
employee
okay nice oh yeah i think he's dead look yeah he's dead look
look i saw him i saw he got eaten you saw him get eaten by
what yeah by the monster oh my god okay then we we go, I
guess.
I guess we have to go now.
Oh, how much?
How many?
How much money we have?
Not a lot.
We made $79.
But we have to go.
Okay.
Go next.
We go next.
Yeah, we go next.
This next.
We have walkie-talkies now.
We give one to RPR.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we give... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give one to RPR.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, he released his employee.
How did you die?
Don't talk to me.
You literally brought the whole army of muttered to me.
What do you mean how I die?
I was so scared.
I was trying to get out.
Yeah, you got out of the experience of my life.
You could have got out too.
I'm here.
Take my walk.
We're gonna help you.
walkie-talkie
you can no walkie-talkie is a waste of space and we need all
the money we can help you find the monsters so you won't get
hurt i don't need your help but you died like twice because
of the monster she needs help okay okay you go inside i'll
use the walkie-talkie okay charge walkie-talkie you should
go no no no no no no no no no no i can i can look at the map
and i'll tell you there's monsters dido okay i'll do i'll do
this i'll do the i'll go out the next day the next day you
guide me but today i guide you okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay i'll tell you Okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I believe in you, Ditto.
Yeah, I believe in you too.
Yeah, yeah, I won't let you die.
I hope you won't like me.
I won't, don't worry, I won't let you die.
Okay, okay.
I saw the B.
Don't get the B.
Don't get the B!
I understand why he's so...
He's so mad.
Wait, there's something to your left.
There's loot.
No, no monsters, no monsters.
I'll let you know there's monsters.
There's a lot of loot though.
Okay, I'm watching.
No monsters.
No loot, no loot.
No loot.
No loot or monsters.
Is there any monster?
No, no, no.
No monsters.
See, I'm doing so well.
I'm such a team player.
I'm helping.
I'm useful.
No monsters, no loot.
Nice, nice.
There you go.
I opened door.
Okay, this here.
Yeah, yeah, no monsters, no loot.
Wait, what number is that?
You're fine, you're fine.
Which way, which way should we go?
Follow RPR, follow him.
Oh, there's loot, there's loot to your left.
Okay, okay, okay, there's loot.
There's loot there, there's loot there's loot.
Look at me!
I'm so good!
I'm so good at this game!
Dead end, dead end
Hmm Yeah, there's loot there, there's Follow RPR, follow
RPR, there's loot
Wait, what is that?
I'm such a team player Oh, I lied, no loot
Follow RPR, follow
RPR.
There's no monsters.
They're perfectly healthy.
Oh, upstairs loot.
Upstairs loot.
See?
Look at that.
I'm so fucking good at this game.
Is there anything downstairs?
I'm so lost looking at this.
Oh!
Lute in center.
Lute there.
Go forward.
Top, top, loot, top, loot.
Or forward, forward, forward.
Follow RPR.
Oh, lift, right, right side, right side, loot.
Go back, go back.
Go back.
Go back, Dido.
Loot.
Wait, did she drop the walkie-talkie?
She can't even hear me.
I just realized.
I just realized she can't even hear me Because she doesn't
have her walkie-talkie out I just realized
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, I can't hear you, I can't hear you Okay, okay, okay We
need more like We need more like 200 Wait, wait, there's
loot to your...
Wait, where are you?
Wait, bring the loot.
I'll come over and bring loot back.
I'll come over.
Okay, okay.
Where am I?
I don't know where the entrance is.
It's not made in time.
Oh.
Where am I?
Is this...
Where is he?
Okay, I'm trying to find the side entrance.
Where am I?
Oh, I see, I see, I hear you!
Hello?
Here, here, this way, this way, this way!
Oh, I see, I see, I see!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I come, I help, I'll help.
Take it back, take it back.
Okay, okay, okay, don't worry.
I'll help you too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got my hands full.
Can we come up here?
No, we can't.
My hands full too.
Wait, how do we go back?
Oh, here, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do we?
Where's the shoe?
Wait, I don't think we can.
We have to jump, jump, jump.
Wait, can we?
And I don't...
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, where?
How can we get up?
Wait, I think we're stuck.
I think we're stuck.
I think... I didn't!
Wait, I think I'm stuck!
I think we can come up from here.
Wait, wait, here.
Maybe here.
Can we?
This way?
Can we get...
Oh, I don't drop down!
Maybe it's too heavy?
Yeah!
No, I can't!
I can't!
No!
We're stuck!
We can't kill him!
We can't get home!
Okay, we can just bring the loot to the other exit.
But where's the other exit?
I don't remember!
Maybe this way.
I remember, just pick the...
Okay, okay, I got the milk.
Okay, okay, okay.
But who gets this?
Where are you?
We just follow him.
Oh, I can't get...
Wait, where are you?
Can you pick up this glass from the ground?
We'll go back and get it later.
Do you have any empty slots?
No, hands full.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here.
Okay, stop.
Okay.
No, I will keep talking.
Oh, wait.
It's down here.
Are you sure you remember?
Yes, I was just there.
Okay.
mom oh
here I'm so scared oh hey there's another exit oh there's
another exit nice okay we have to go back there's still like
two items there's still two more items we left in the exit
wait did we yeah we didn't take everything yeah we can't
yeah yeah there was like a big item we didn't pick up oh can
you get the walkie-talkie too i think we took everything no
no no we left the walkie-talkie i don't know that was 20
dollars oh i see i see the ship oh we can we we can't sell
this walkie-talkie all right nice we had like it was like no
we actually left a big item though all right no we took it
no there was a big item there wasn't it yeah but i took it
in oh i had empty slots i didn't realize she had an empty
slot i had three empty slots so we lost we lost a
walkie-talkie for no reason okay and here's so how much
money do we make oh we made 275
there's things inside here we did it for we need 389 for we
need 389 though we have enough how much more days do we have
what this was our last day we gotta go in there then yeah we
gotta go in there pick up one more thing okay we can sell
our walkie-talkies there no there cost nothing i don't think
we can sell it oh okay do you want me to hold okay i can
help i'll help wait but it's 8 9 we can we can take the
honey come we can take the bees the bees oh the bees yeah
the bees yeah yeah how much is the bees it's like 70 or 80
or something oh wait the bees yeah the bees and we make it
wait giant giant okay you can take the bees but do you know
how to do it no just pick it up and run to the ship oh i did
i watch the giant the giants she's come here kids come here
take the bees take the bees oh my god no no the science the
science beside the bee no he's not he's he's there he's
there he's there near near the bees what what what what what
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running
he's running he's running I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die did
you guys take it no they don't got scared she can still grab
you he's grab you here we need to take it or we lose rpr did
it got scared and then the giant started chasing us i think
diddo died no she's alive oh she's alive yeah maybe she
grabbed the bees she didn't did you get the bees did you
okay i'll go get the no i don't get it i don't get it we
believe in you rpr i can't get it there's there's a giant
beast I'm not near the bees wait I'm here I'm your day he's
not he's still alive he's moving oh he's not oh shit oh yeah
he's moving he's gonna grab it I'm gonna dance for victory I
believe in him too yeah but he didn't grab the bees he
grabbed an item I are I say oh oh I think The ship is
leaving.
I think the ship is leaving.
The ship is leaving.
I think he was too late.
You guys are not real.
It doesn't matter if you die to the giant.
Just pick up the loot or we lose anyway.
I'm not serious.
There was an engine there.
They killed everything they had.
You lived in, then what?
They lost.
We still lost.
They don't could have grabbed it.
I don't care.
They don't could have grabbed it when he was chasing.
She could have grabbed it.
One of you died, the other one, take the B.
Yeah, to know.
He was chasing me.
It wasn't my fault.
That's good!
Wait, we need $10.
One body is like $10, right?
No, it's...
One body.
How much is...
Ah, that's me!
It was Dinosaur!
I swear!
It wasn't my fault!
Dinosaur!
It was not my fault!
You need to die for the company.
No, I did it!
I did it!
I did so...
You both need to die for the company.
The more money, the better.
Only one of us have...
No!
Only one of us!
There is behind you!
There is behind!
Huh?
All these things...
Man, what do you mean?
Why are you getting paranoid?
You think you're safe?
You think you're safe!
No, don't jump off!
You're gonna make a fool again.
Why are you running?
I'm not running, I'm not running.
Why are you killing us?
Why are you trying to kill us?
Because your body is worth money!
How about your body?
Well, I got the shovel don't I?
Yeah, you're gonna die.
Okay, then we're gonna lose.
Fuck it, let's lose.
I sacrificed my body!
I will sell your body, I will sell your body.
I will sell your life.
Ah, it's important.
It's important.
It's okay, it's okay that we'll win the game.
We're like, we're gonna win the game of our body.
Are we gonna make it?
Yeah, because it's $10.
We just needed $10, I think.
I think we just needed that $10.
Yeah, yeah, we just needed that $10.
Oh, we do.
Blask.
Oh, yeah.
There's more.
If he knows, we need anything we can get.
Do I sell the walkie-talkie chat?
Sell the walkie-talkie?
I don't know.
Why is he so mad?
I don't...
Yeah, he's so mad.
Yeah, why is he so mad?
I don't understand.
Maybe we make him wake up too early.
Yeah, maybe it's because it's too early.
How much money do we get?
How much do we get?
should we get we should have we should have like enough
right we're short 25 25 25 then what's the point of killing
us 45 25 25 if only one engine or one beehive the nine of
them took but had two take but instead they were running
because living is more important than making money for the
company now we die all of us we die as a team we die as a
team yeah we die as a team yeah we die if uto was here if
uto was here We would have made the money.
We would have made the money of Uto in C.
If one of you picked up the beehive or the engine or the
other person is being chased by the giant, I was being
chased by a giant.
I was being chased by a giant.
Just die for the die for the car to die.
It's unbelievable.
I try your best If I don't wish like this, you are so
aggressive today Holy shit After all of that That's what you
said to me, Ditto Guys, I will have a meeting in 10 minutes
You have a meeting?
Yes, I have a meeting You're calling it here.
Is this GG?
So we're done here.
Are we finally done?
We did it.
Are we finally done with this culture?
Next time.
Utopia here, guys.
Oh my god.
Yay.
I'm free from this pain.
oh my god i thought it was never gonna end i thought it was
gonna suffer here for i had a great time guys it was a great
i had a great time playing with yeah great time this was so
fun so fun we had a lot of fun yeah i learned so much i
learned so much working in this company yeah you guys
definitely you did so much work yeah yeah you guys did so
much work i'm really happy to working Happy to work with you
too.
You're a great leader.
Yeah, yeah.
You're a nice opportunity.
I was so happy.
Like, if I could, if I could, like, compare working with you
guys to anything, it's almost like playing 1v9 in League of
Legends.
You were a great leader, RPI.
Great boss.
Good boss.
I can't handle you guys.
Even though you were the laziest employee, we think you were
the best employee.
I'm the laziest!
Did you see how much money I made us every run?
You bought a toilet with my hard-earned money.
You bought a toilet.
I was just reading the game set.
You bought a toilet with my money.
I was just reading the result.
Yeah, I just read what the game said.
Delicious employment.
A fucking toilet!
You could have bought anything else.
A boob box and a toilet.
It was a good boob box.
good time you could have put a stun gun a shovel anything i
bought walkie-talkies yeah as i'm making money for you to
survive you guys are planning to kill me in front of the
main entrance with stop signs how are you real how is this
real we were just talking it was like girl talk right it was
girl talk you get so much money and then i die to a break
that snaps my neck in half And then I expected you guys to
see what you guys are doing.
Maybe you guys are making money But no, you guys are
standing by the door and saying we have enough money We also
made money back making money for you.
You're trying to murder me.
You're plotting to kill me But if we if you didn't die we
could have made more money If I didn't die you would have
killed me.
No, we wouldn't we were doing girl time.
We wouldn't yeah We wouldn't you wouldn't understand you're
not you don't understand girl talk Sometimes we just say I'm
joke we were joking.
Yeah, yeah, we're like JK Yeah, ha ha ha if you were like if
you were respecting us earlier you could tell they don't
know we were like Okay, let's pretend we're gonna kill him.
It'll be so funny.
We pretend.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, we're gonna scare him You guys really
after years of knowing you guys you guys think I believe
anything that comes out of your mouth I don't ever it's dumb
and dumber I hear from them dumb and dumber if Uto was here
too you wouldn't yell at us if Uto was here you wouldn't
yell at us yeah cuz Uto's an actual angel that would try to
get us out of this god-forsaken planet while you two are
sabotaging my hard fucking work.
I'm only Uta was here.
This is insane.
I feel 20 years older after this.
It's not even fungy.
I had a great time, guys.
Someone clip this whole thing, bro.
The descend into madness.
I start up.
I start off as a normal working employee and as we keep
going I become a fucking villain bro You turn me into the
fucking Joker in like an hour
You don't have to be this man just come down come down You
can get HR in here We can get HR in here It's not good for
your health, you know Yeah, yeah, it's not good You're aging
or you're getting older You need to calm down The stress
isn't good for you Your blood pressure is is right rising
right here you gotta calm down i'm only 27.
it's not good for you see i told you the stress isn't good
for you right now your stress isn't good for you you guys
you guys you guys you guys yeah you'll get older faster you
could you could put a perfectly healthy man into a mental
institution in two hours
Cheers, guys.
Yay.
I'm taking the bag off.
I'm done.
He's done.
Oh my god.
I had a great time, guys.
Next time, I will I will deny the chat with the time.
Yeah, look at next.
Next time.
If Uto joins and she's as bad as you guys, I will jump over
the fucking ship as we start playing every single time Why
would you do that?
Were she?
Uto better not be corrupted by you two fucking demons No, we
won't We're not demons for angels She's good like us Yeah,
there's no way she's gonna be like us Like us We're good
people.
We're good people.
We made us money.
You two demons spawned of hell.
Both of you.
We'll be fine.
We'll be okay.
We'll be okay, guys.
I had, you know, guys, I had a great time.
I had, yeah, me too.
I had a great time.
It was amazing time.
So my fun.
It was so fun guys.
So fucking fun.
It was so fun.
Yeah, see?
You thought it was fun.
See?
So fun.
Yeah, great fun.
Here, do you need a hug?
Do you need a hug?
I'm going to alt it for in five seconds.
Say your last words right now.
You were a great leader, Arthur.
What did she say?
I didn't say that.
She said that.
What did she say?
I didn't say anything.
You are the good employee.
Employee.
Yeah.
You are paid the debt.
I said you were a great leader.
You're a part-timer.
I said you were great.
I was a good partner.
Yeah.
Can we self-destruct this fucking shit?
GG's, guys.
GG's.
I had a good time.
I'll see you guys next time.
We're with Uto this time.
Yeah, good game, guys.
Can't wait for another one of these.
Yay!
Bye-bye, guys.
Goodbye.
Guys, I think I had a great time, everybody.
Guys, you heard RPR.
You had a great time.
Neil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And I'm staying for the entire stream since 3 a.m.
And I don't regret one bit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think we had good teamwork.
We worked really well together.
Chat.
What do you mean?
Anyways, I think we had a good time together, everyone.
I still can't believe.
They don't organize this collection.
have and she forgot to tell Uto that I thought that was the
funniest shit because she told me an RPR but then she forgot
the fuck Uto
oh my god holy shit I had a great time this was great it was
it was good teamwork I think we, I think, I think we had a
really good teamwork.
Rose, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got to tell him, but it was hilarious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Without us, our peer wouldn't be able to move the money.
Ditto and I got all the money to the ship.
What are you guys talking about?
We move all the money to the ship.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Next week, by the way, next week's going to be little bit i
don't actually i'm trying to remember what we have next week
um all right challenger circuit uh lgs challenger circuit is
like semi-confirmed um i will be participating in the
challenger circuit um i think it's like saturday sunday
monday if you make it to the final so mostly it may be just
saturday so um i will be doing that with nice wig and tempo
um so um We're just waiting on Wig to like sign us up, but
he's like, he's going to be signing us up and he said it's
going to be on the 22nd, I think.
22nd, or was it 23rd?
I don't remember.
It's like, it's 20th.
I don't, let me, wait.
I actually don't remember.
Whichever day Challenger Circuit starts next week.
But we're going to be doing LGS Challenger Circuit with nice
Wig.
and tempo next week i don't remember if it was like saturday
sunday or monday oh uh and also um i'm trying to remember
any other updates i have to give you guys uh but i think
that's really i got like so many like i got like invites to
some like uh another like a turn lots of tournaments
recently so like to the point where i actually have to like
uh pick and choose what to participate tournament invites um
and i actually had to for the first time i actually like to
decline a tournament it was um a tournament because i just
had too much going on um so it's crazy i actually had to
decline a tournament off like a tournament invite it's
supposed to be like a pal another pal world tournament but
it's just like i'm gonna i i have i have like apex stuff
going on next week i can't do both i can't do both
um but yeah other than that i think that is really uh that
is really up the only updates i have for you guys i am so
i'm so tired i took like a little nap before the stream
because i was like oh my god oh my god okay um alredo
originally um we were supposed to do 5 p.m pst but then uh
because like for rpr he's still in uh he's still in eu so um
um we had to change the time so at first like we suggested 8
a.m p.m i'm sorry 8 a.m pst and i was like no because i was
like i can stay up but i cannot wake up saturday so i was
like yeah no not a 8 a.m i cannot do 8 a.m so so we settled
on like 1 a.m.
because I was like I can't guys 1 a.m.
there's too much guys like I'm not wanting 8 a.m.
there's too much I cannot do mornings I can only I can only
stay up I can only stay up until like 3 like 3 to 4 a.m.
I cannot wake up at 8 a.m.
so he settled on 1 a.m.
anyway guys
Oh my god, I didn't even realize my music was, my BGM was
off.
But I'm going to call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time for everybody in the NA
that stayed up.
Now you know how the Dragoons on the other side of the world
feels like.
It's your turn.
It was your turn to stay up.
It's your turn now, Dragoons and NA, to stay up for D-Gen
hours.
Anyway, everybody, as always, everyone, stay hydrated,
posture checked.
Get up and move around.
get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye